[Music]
meagan Markel has officially stepped out
with queen elizabeth the 36 year old
actress has been busy gearing up for her
may 19th nuptials to Prince Harry but on
Monday she took a break from all the
wedding planning to attend her first
royal public event alongside her majesty
at the Commonwealth service at
Westminster Abbey the humanitarian wowed
in white for the occasion donning a
cream-colored
Amanda Wakeley coat a white Stephen
Jones hat Navy Manolo Blahnik heels and
a matching mulberry clutch and yes her
fiance was by her side
Queen Elizabeth looked equally regal in
this all burgundy ensemble while Kate
Middleton who is pregnant with her third
child and Prince William wowed in navy
during the Commonwealth Day service
Markel was caught on camera singing the
national anthem of the United Kingdom
God saved the Queen
[Music]
having Meaghan at the event was a break
in royal protocol for the Queen but it's
not the first time she has made an
exception for the former suit star to
join them prior to exchanging vows with
Harry the bride-to-be was previously
invited to spend Christmas with the
family and even attended their Christmas
Day service